in any one point in this conflict,
how many people are pregnant
what happens when they're displaces, what happens to them
and to their pregnancies? it's estimated that 25- 30% of women
and then what happens to...
what kind of care do they have access to?
women who are attacked, what happens to their family structure,
what happens in their communities, what happens to them physically
and I just couldn’t just stop thinking about it
I just wanted to figure out a way to help
or contribute in some way to the work that was being done
the hospital had various
forms in various ways of keeping records but
starting in about 2004, 2005
their records became more consistent
and their data collection became more consistent
and the forms that we looked at were the psycho-social intake forms
and
when a woman comes to Panzi hospital to
seek care for
herself after enduring sexual violence
she meets with a social worker
who does the intake form
some of it includes quantitative data, was the woman
married, demographics, widowed or abandoned, how many children,
how old was she, level of education
and then there's more data about the incident
itself.
what was the date of the incident
how many assailants
were involved
what time of day did this occur
where did this happen
and then following that information is a narrative
and that is
written down
in the words of the woman who's being interviewed
and then there is a psycho-social assessment
and so an assessment of the level of trauma
that the woman has experienced
there were 1,021
charts from 2006
for the past few months I've been
analyzing the data
and understanding more the relationships between
where did the attacks occur
what characteristics make
certain women more vulnerable
and a lot of information has come from the
study which has been useful
for directing programs and policy
we came back with the intention to the analyze
2005,
2007 and 2008
and so
we met with three Congolese
residents who have
experience with data entry and
are currently training them to enter in the
data.
We looked at the charts for 2005
today and counted them
and there were
approximately 1200 charts just from 2005
so I'm suspecting it'll be about the same for
each year,
it's about probably about 35-3600
and those are just the women who came to Panzi,
and what about the women that can't reach Panzi,
have they sought care somewhere else, are they still at home
too ashamed or too
too upset to come in and
seek care
we only seeing the ones who have the means to be able to get to Panzi hospital